christophe derrière ça fait quoi d'avoir
un nom de famille qui ne voit pas du
tout il a un petit buzzer on va
expliquer pourquoi comme oui parce que
j'ai tu le sais pas ce que tu me le dise
voilà une autre séquence non vous savez
chez thierry ardisson je suis je pose
les questions trop con que thierry
ardisson n'a pas voulu poser et là on se
concerter avec cyril et du coup j'ai
écrit les questions que cyril ne
voudrais pas vous posez donc il ya plein
de questions sur tous les membres
ça peut tomber à n'importe quel manager
et je voudrais dire quelque chose
vraiment je suis très très très très fan
de tom est biaisé c'est bien alors j'ai
une première question chez le maire
michel
il ya beaucoup de rumeurs qui traînent
sur internet c'est vrai que jean michel
lemaire en thaïlande il ya une mst qui
porte votre nom
j'adore cette émission cette émission
démarre très bien j'aime bien la
clarification pour daniel mans mais vu
que vous êtes célibataire on en parle
vous vivez chez votre maman vous aimez
les hommes plus vieux et vous bossez
danse est au programme
ça fait pas beaucoup de handicaps d'un
coup qu'on trouvait m
ah oui bon pour en faire une tout de
suite oui j'en ai une petite pour pour
matthieu delormeau et un cyril vous avez
dit qu'il avait un projet pour vous de
quatre prime
par contre vous étiez au courant que
c'était pour le regarder de chez vous et
c'est là les bras ballants sur m6 pour
masquer or merci arrivent avec leurs
beats et leurs couteaux alors tout seul
maintenant à c'est à dire un truc je
savais qu'il fallait qu'on arrive
justement c'est pour rebondir par
rapport à jean michel maire jean-michel
je crois que vous avez été correspondant
de guerre en bosnie à l'époque vous
partie avec votre but est votre couteau
du coup aujourd'hui n'est pas le
malheureux votre couteau question une
petite question pour matthieu delormeau
avant vous étiez analystes financiers je
crois ça veut dire qu'avant syrie les ja
vous étiez spécialiste des bourses
à l'hectare sont christophe derrière ça
fait quoi d'avoir un nom de famille qui
ne voudrait pas du tout
[Applaudissements]
il est en forme
je peux me permettre cyril j'ai une
petite question pour matthieu delormeau
tout à l'heure a vanté pmp il a présenté
il en pense quoi mathieu il vraiment
besoin de répondre à cette question
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]